hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle i am your host mark ellis this is
the show where we have two incredible
panelists and they're going to be
debating all things about one specific
topic in the world of entertainment so
why not tackle stranger things we just
had the second half of season four drop
so there will be heavy spoilers for all
four seasons possibly of stranger things
during this episode so you've not yet
checked out any of season four they
would hit pause on this go check that
out and come on back when you're as
prepared as our two panelists here today
five rounds possible four rounds
definite in each round they're going to
be debating a bunch of things that we
saw that we seen that we heard that we
loved or maybe hated in season four of
stranger things and so without further
ado your panelist today your first one a
dear friend of mine well they're both
dear friends of mine until the nba
playoffs and then we have a fervent text
thread that um i cannot repeat on this
show because it's a family program he is
part of the first cut youtube channel
you can catch a bunch of movie reviews
some podcasting occasionally and he
happens to be a world-class
director whose short film time stamp has
made the festival rounds and has won
some awards already he's robert butler
iii hello robert welcome back to binge
battle how you doing bud
uh i'm doing great i'm doing great happy
to be here so let me ask you this
stranger things dropped back back in in
the old days back in season one were you
like aware of stranger things coming out
were you like oh what is this thing did
you just kind of catch the social media
wave like everybody else and binge it
right away did you take your time what
was your entry point into stranger
things way back when i definitely
remember seeing the trailer uh pop off
when it when it first came out uh back
in
uh and i remember watching it pretty
immediately
i didn't necessarily love the first
season as much as everybody else because
i'm not the biggest fan of like you know
some of the some of the 80s nostalgia
kind of wave you know that has kind of
been going on during that time period
but
needless to say i fell in love with the
characters i fell in love with the story
and right now i'm i'm a huge stranger
things fan you know
look at that
yeah well look sometimes you have to
have lived through the 80s to want to
remember it so
you're uh
your combatant today is a dear friend of
yours and mind as well you can also
catch him doing reviews and a bunch of
other great things with the first cut he
is the one the only column ace because
he wins a lot of showdown matches in
years past andres cabrera welcome back
to the show andre's what's going on bud
what is up man how are you doing i mean
this is this is just like us hanging out
again except yeah watching your phoenix
sons who made the playoffs or roberts
ellie lakers who checks notes did not
make the playoffs and so um it's not
going to be quite as heated as that but
it's still going to be fun talking
stranger things your introduction to
stranger things andres do you remember
loving it or do you remember kind of
warming up to it like robert did oh i
loved it right off the bat and and i
also remember watching it right when it
dropped uh it was definitely reaching a
lot of hype and i jumped right on the
train and sure enough it delivered and
it's definitely uh the staple netflix
show now which is amazing
it really is we might talk about the
future of stranger things if we have
time at the end of this show but that is
in the future right here and now we're
about to kick off binge battle with our
first round keep in mind each round you
competitors get up to a minute for your
opening statement you get up to 30
seconds for your rebuttal and then i'll
set you all up for a closing statement
which is your mic drop moment putting a
cap on the round and your argument at
the end of that i will have to choose
between two dear allies of mine and give
them a point whoever has the most points
at the end of the match wins we could go
to sudden death possibly we're not there
yet where we are is topic number one in
round at number one and it's all about
the season for conclusion we're finally
there we made it through two i guess
volumes segments of season four it is
now finito so was it good was it bad was
it okay where did it stand for you
andres cabrera kicking us off here one
minute on the clock i thought season
four was really good i thought the
conclusion wrapped up really well
i thought the length of it
at first it seemed overwhelming but it
all came together the pacing i feel like
is what the duffer brothers are really
good at they know how to pace stories
how to pace characters and i feel like
that pacing allows them to tell a story
a complete story with with each
character having their own moment their
own character uh time to breathe and to
allow themselves to have this time
between themselves before they face this
giant upside down battle between them
and vecna so i felt like the conclusion
was good obviously it always can be
better but man it really is satisfying
to see the leveling up of this season
with the production budget with the
music and with everything that came with
it so i thought season four was good man
the pacing was on point and that budget
certainly showed up on screen over to
you robert butler the third how do you
feel about season four's conclusion well
first of all talking about season four
in general i love season four i thought
this was one of the best seasons of
stranger things in general um i love the
new characters that we got introduced to
argyle a pineapple on pizza fan um eddie
is one of my new favorite characters rp
um you know we got to see lucas you know
getting on the bass parkour and hooping
so there's a whole lot of surprises that
i didn't anticipate seeing this season
that um really really surprised me that
being said though i do think the last
episode the finale of season four was a
little bit underwhelming i thought it
was just okay and the reason i think
it's just okay is because um what we've
been building up to this entire season
has been seeing 11 um cooking and
cooking in the lab with dr brenner and
like really trying to develop her powers
and hit that full maximum power set and
i felt like when we finally hit the
finale we didn't get that maximum
superpower
like 11 that i was kind of looking
forward to seeing the most like she
should have been like some wanda you
know from like one division or or
something like that or she should have
really been like taking it to the next
level and she did piggyback um to off of
max's mind to you know fight vector
which was really really cool and was a
pretty big power upgrade but you know as
we're going to talk about later i
thought she had an even bigger more
cooler moment in the previous episode
episode 8 when she had escaped from the
compound and like blew everything up so
that being said like i i really enjoy
season four but
sees the season four conclusion it was
it was a little longer than it needed to
be and it didn't give me exactly what i
wanted um for the power set for 11. two
great ways to open an argument there and
it took robert all of i believe seven
seconds to reference pineapple on pizza
so another hot debate amongst our
friendship let's go back to you andres
because robert feels like maybe some
meat left on the bone there wanting to
realize more of a weapon's full
potential your rebuttal
yeah i feel like that's a big
point i feel like that's very purposeful
from the duffer brothers they wanted to
have kind of a moment where even mike
says it at the end of the of the episode
where he says eleven's never lost before
and this is kind of a moment where she
does lose and i feel like that's gonna
come back in season five when eventually
she does come into her own powers she
does level up to the way that brenner or
papa predicted that she could be to a
point where vekna is so completely
overpowered that even the upside down is
probably going to bend to 11's will so i
think we're going to see huge power up
with 11 in season five and i thought
it's it's kind of crazy how nancy was
kind of a big hero
in the big star uh defeating vekma more
than even eleven was and i feel like
that's very much done on purpose so i i
kind of like that i like that there's
different characters kind of stepping up
and it's not just goku winning
over and over again shout out to dragon
ball z but it's always kind of annoying
when the main character just is the only
one that wins the fight and it's not any
of the side characters that we also
enjoy uh that can also win a fight so i
think that's a cool thing that stranger
things brought into this finale and goku
has entered the chat back to you robert
butler the third it seems like the crux
of ichiel's arguments is how you felt
about 11 so
continue mr butler when we talk about
how
uh 11 you know she she did have that she
did have moments
she didn't she never had a moment of
losing and this was kind of a moment of
like a bit of a failure but i felt like
the the show wanted to like have his
cake and eat it too a little bit because
i felt like we had that big epic finale
where the city's kind of splitting into
pieces and you know things are kind of
like really looking dower that might
have been a much stronger moment to end
the episode on then giving us another 45
minutes of all the characters meeting
each other again like wrapping up i
think what was so unique about the
season is that all of the characters had
their separate adventures all in like
different locations but they still found
a way to like be together somehow but
then at the end of the season we still
had another like 30 40 minutes of
everybody like oh hey good to see you
again oh hey like how you doing i didn't
love that that much that could have been
i don't need the two and a half hour
version give me the two hour cut and
give me the empire strikes back the the
real deep and dark ending to it too all
right so back to andres cabrera for your
final statement here in a heated round
one
yeah i feel like them coming together
was almost kind of needed for the
audience i think the audience needs to
see that these characters are gonna team
up and are gonna unite for the final
battle for season five and we still do
kind of get an empire strikes back uh
final shot with them looking over
hawkins and seeing hawkins with the
gateway to the upside down kind of split
in half and kind of prepping for that
final battle between them and vector and
obviously we see the will spine tingling
moment as well which also kind of shows
you that oh okay the real battle is
still ahead of you so i still feel like
that is still there but adding a little
bit of now we know that 11 for sure
knows that hopper is alive now that we
know that these characters are coming
back together now we know where max is
at currently in the storyline as well i
feel like all those moments were kind of
needed and if we left those questions up
in the air it would have been a little
bit too tedious for them to wait
two years or three years for season five
and not know what's going on with those
characters all right robert butler the
third i'm still making my decision you
have the final statement in round one
yeah you know and i i definitely agree
that having those characters
reintroduced to each other and get back
in line is definitely an asset there's
so much in this season we've seen so
many long episodes so many different
story lines so many locations that at a
certain point is like it's where we make
the cuts right i felt like they
sacrificed a lot of 11's super amazing
powerful moments that she could have
potentially had for
less satisfying i guess from a character
perspective satisfying but from an
audience perspective not as many
satisfying like kind of re recompanion
shot recompanion moments that we got at
the end of the episode all right so that
is it for round number one and you know
i i try to take my own opinion out of
this because i really did enjoy what
stranger things did throughout season
four the conclusion itself i did feels a
little long in the tooth and i feel like
some of the reunions were like okay
let's let's get this thing going a
little bit
but
i do feel like it was necessary to serve
the audience as andres had said and we
are still setting stuff up but we don't
know when we're getting season five just
yet and so i do think that the audience
kind of needed those reunion moments and
you all weren't alive back then but the
80s that's what it was all about baby
was reunions and so i'm gonna give a
point to andres cabrera by the thinnest
of margins i promise it had nothing to
do with the pineapple on pizza reference
robert i'm taking my own feelings on pie
out of this so andres goes up one
nothing but now we go to round number
two and we're gonna celebrate the
greatness that we got the things that we
loved in season four we're gonna start
with you robert butler iii what was the
best season four moment in your opinion
uh well it was a moment i kind of
alluded to a minute ago uh the moment
when 11 escapes the compound she finally
gets out and it's the moment where papa
dr brenner actually kind of helps her
escape because the military invades the
entire laboratory and is taking
everybody out left and right 11 is
getting chased by helicopters mad
vehicles mad gunfire all around the
place and we see her this whole time
like struggling throughout the whole
season with her powers like she had it
through sporadic moments here or there
but this was the first time we actually
got that full
unlocked power set through and through
and she managed to take control of the
entire helicopter on some like darth
vader you know obi-wan joint took it
down and literally just threw it to the
ground exploded all the vehicles and the
whole interest of the compound and it
felt like the most epic
true action movie sci-fi movie moment of
all time if you know like the those
classic you know action movies where the
character is looking at the explosion
and that's also what i enjoyed about it
and the season where in a show that has
a lot of sci-fi elements and a lot of
digital visual effects
you can very much tell this was like a
practical explosion shot in a very
isolated desert it kind of gave like
very matrix vibes to it as well so i
really really dug this moment to me this
was like the epic triumphant and like
like we've been joking about it's it's
the character who's been
in the compound been training the entire
season finally getting out and making
that splash you can't beat that
yeah kind of reminded me of ray in the
desert in the rise of skywalker just
really taking control of a [ __ ] just
like whoa what are we in for here let's
go over andres cabrera for your best
moment of season four yeah i think it's
the moment that everyone was talking
about back in volume one the one that
took over tick-tock took over the
internet uh it really is
in the reason why is because it's a
really incredible moment and that's the
running up that hill
max escaping the upside down from vecna
moment
where we see a character of vecna being
introduced all the way in episode one
attacking chrissy taking over her mind
uh demeaning her to the point of
reaching
uh death in the most horrific manner so
we know the stakes that that are set up
in in pretty much the entire season for
episode four with max so we're so afraid
that max is not only going to die but
die in the most horrific manner possible
and she's going to die with trauma that
is placed in her head that she herself
is holding on to there's so much heart
inside that episode and there's so much
heart inside that moment where the music
plays and she chooses her favorite song
which is running up that hill and has
this emotional context of remembering
her friends uh her heart her family and
realizing that she is worth it and her
life is worth moving forward to and she
does want to escape and her escaping his
her own fight to really break out of the
upside down and i feel like that moment
encompasses what stranger things is all
about which is about friendship it's
about being yourself it's about pushing
past your own trauma and your own fear
and it's incredible because it combines
all those things inside one episode and
one moment it reminded me of a great 80s
running back walter payton how he used
to train in the offseason just running
up a hill all day uh let's go back to
robert butler the third here for your
rebuttal we got two really good
arguments y'all picked you know i
definitely can't deny the running up the
hill moment as being one of the most
iconic moments of the show period i mean
i'm just right that song's been trending
on tick tock nonstop um i definitely
think that it for one i think it's it's
a great moment that's visually beautiful
i also think it gets slightly undercut
later on in the season because we end up
going back to
max getting controlled by vector again
and actually dying if we think she's
dying or she has you know she died for a
minute or something like that so we
ended up having that whole beautiful
scene and beautiful moment not for
nothing but ultimately just to establish
like plot elements meanwhile this moment
for 11 is her penultimate climactic
moment as her as a character because you
got to remember her and papa's
relationship has been antagonistic since
season one dr brennan was in the show
since season one she he was a doctor who
was controlling her manipulating her and
you know we think he gets eaten by this
demi gorgon but he ends up coming back
and surprising her and surprising the
audience with his return in this season
so you know he comes in he's
manipulating 11 he's controlling her
he's literally
he still has that brace around 11 so she
doesn't even have full access to his
powers but even still with that in the
face of the moment in the heat of the
moment she still gets enough control
enough power to make this giant epic
explosion and we get this also really
beautiful subtle moment between dr
brenner and 11 2 where she says goodbye
to papa but you know papa says oh i love
you but she's not she's definitely not
gonna say it back because he's like the
abusive dad that she's had the entire
time so there's a lot a lot of layers to
this moment um that i really really
enjoyed there's a whole lot of emotional
content in that one sequence uh back to
you andres
yeah i feel like a lot of that moment a
lot of that scene is based on how much
you buy into the papa and eleven
relationship and i for one cannot stand
dr brenner cannot stand papa and i i
really do feel like if there's any
character who's probably one of the most
annoying i know a lot of people said
jason but my god give me jason over
brenner i think brenner is the most
annoying character in the show and i
feel like a lot of that emotional
context was already dealt with in season
one and season two where she moved past
dr brenner uh meeting the other uh
numbers and meeting the other characters
and and really talking through her
emotions as far as what her emotional
weight from papa was especially with
hopper too because hopper helped her
move past that as well so i feel like
that a lot of that for me was so tedious
to the point that the the moment where
she pulls down the helicopter is more of
a cool shot than a cool moment i feel
like the moment is really something
where you embody and you encompass a lot
inside one scene and that's exactly what
max does for
running up that hill inside the upside
down where she encompasses her past
trauma her past relationships and her
past friendships and tries to move
forward especially being someone who's a
young girl and who's facing almost these
thoughts of suicide and these thoughts
of regretting her own life and
regretting her own thoughts so i feel
like moving past that and fighting that
and seeing an actual
batting battling your actual demons
while facing down a demon is is really
kind of the unique factor of what
stranger things can deliver where
they're literally giving you the
embodiment of your fears and your trauma
inside vecna and inside the upside down
and breaking free from that is just a
true example of what the duffer brothers
can do with the show like stranger
things so i feel like that moment just
embodies everything from stranger things
i like that a lot facing your
your inner demons while facing a literal
demon
it's a full day's work that max has put
it in here uh we're gonna go back to
robert butler the third you have the
first opening and closing statement here
in round two you know they have to deal
with their trauma and fight the trauma
the same way that the ig clown made um
the kids deal with that and and and and
this too and even though this is
definitely a better version of it i
didn't like it chapter two so i
definitely think this is a better
version of like haunting kids based on
their mental illness and things of that
nature but that being said though it's
not like we haven't seen this already
but with 11 we haven't seen her come
we've seen her come out of her shell and
we've seen her um get established but
throughout the season we've seen her get
her kick kick doing through all the way
down from the beginning of the season
from her getting bullied when we're
watching those flashbacks being trained
with the other numbers and and all of
that nature so we see a whole lifetime
of trauma that she's also dealing with
and that she's also going and with max
we've seen her deal with problems and
trauma before in the past but a lot of
that stuff kind of really came at the
beginning of this season and felt more
of like a device to get vecna to haunt
her and again that's something that
we've seen already before but we haven't
seen 11 have like this full like
breakdown full rock bottom moment that
she had at the beginning of the season
and then ultimately rise above that and
conquer her trauma conquer her past and
conquer her relationships with dr
brenner and by the way you said you
didn't like dr bernie you you hated him
that's that's also why i love this
moment because we see him die he's dead
after this so he's dead dead um so yeah
if anything you should be loving this
moment too i mean did that did that sway
you at all andres now it's your final
statement no because i feel like he
should have been dead a long time ago uh
i mean i just feel like the character
was dragged out for so long
every episode that he was in every
monologue that he made i just felt like
man they're really milking the crap out
of this actor which i mean he's a great
actor but i felt like the character
itself has really worn out his stay back
in season one or season two where he
should have been eliminated already uh
and i feel like those moments for 11
moving on in the beginning of season
four part one uh with her being bullied
i thought those moments were more
interesting and was more of an uphill
battle than even dr brenner was because
it felt like a more social aspect to
eleven's life and how does she move on
from being a lab rat essentially her
entire life so i feel like that moment
is disconnected even from the brenner
moment where
it it it presents a different challenge
where the brenner challenge is just kind
of going back and retrospecting towards
a previous uh seasons and towards
previous episodes uh whereas i feel like
the max one is her growing as a
character and her moving on as a
character and her really establishing
herself as one of the greatest
characters inside stranger things uh
unlike before because before max wasn't
really a huge part of the crew and she
didn't really have a huge moment and now
she has one of the biggest moments in
all of stranger things that really
embodies a lot of what a lot of teens
actually feel like they feel a lot of uh
you know past regret and past trauma so
i feel like her moving on
really just
encompasses and embodies a lot of what
the audience feels and her breaking
through that through music which is
something that's even more incredible
because everyone can relate to their
favorite song or their favorite
soundtrack can really feel and can
really relate to that moment with max it
was nice to see a character get their
full shine like that in that moment and
but yeah you know you could say the same
for 11 as well because like teenagers go
through some stuff you know we've all
been there y'all a little more recently
than me but you go through stuff and and
it's and it is about battling and it's
about overcoming and so i think that any
teenager could look at either one of
these characters that was sort of
highlighting here as to say okay they
got through that i can get through
whatever i'm going through but we've
been with 11 since really the start of
the show and to see that moment not just
the cool physical alert of a of an
action sequence but also to have the
emotional sort of um you know to see her
sort of matriculate away from papa i
thought was a very important moment for
the show i'm with andres where i at the
beginning of the season i was like why
are we dealing with dr brenner again
what did have we gotten past this but i
think that what we saw in season four
leading up to that moment warranted the
return of matthew modine so homework for
both y'all go see vision quest and
memphis bell because matthew modine is
great in him and then
i'm giving the point to robert butler
iii for the 11 moment and so here we go
it is one to one and y'all really did
some work getting ready for this binge
battle this is a good one these are some
of the best arguments i've ever heard on
the show in regards to anything folks so
let's keep it cooking here as we go to
round number three now and it's simple
best character starting with you andres
cabrera best character is the character
i just named i feel like the character
that really took over the season uh and
the character that that shined more than
any other character and that had the
most to do like truly had the most to do
was max and i feel like max grew as a
character became beloved as a character
had incredible moments as a character
and just really showed who she is in the
group and who she can be and not just
kind of fade in the background like
other side characters have in the past
but really be one of the emotional
hearts of the entire show and one of the
most emotional beats of the entire show
because she's placed in a position
that's unlike the other characters she
doesn't come from the same middle class
background as the other kids she comes
from a poor class background she lives
in a trailer park and she deals with
certain issues and certain stuff that
the other kids don't deal with when it
comes to family matters and when it
comes to family situations she comes
from her broken home she comes from her
broken background and she's dealing with
this trauma with her brother who she
doesn't know how to feel about because
she has these conflicted feelings so i
feel like max truly coming to who she is
and to who she always was inside
stranger things is what makes her the
best character of the season all right
and yeah suddenly said you're laying the
groundwork for your argument in a
previous round we saw rb3 do that in the
first round kind of hinting at what he
was going to talk about in the second
round so there's a lot of strategy going
on here in binge battle this episode too
back to you robert butler the third i
will then mow you 20 bucks if you pick
dr brenner just to mess with
andre don't do it
i would definitely i won't be dr brennan
i won't have no legs to stand on because
i don't really like that dude either um
but i um i definitely gotta shout out my
man eddie you know eddie is one of those
characters stranger things does the
thing where they introduce a new
character every season multiple new
characters every season and some live
some die
unfortunately eddie didn't make it all
the way through r.i.p but he died
fighting for a city that hated him all
the way through hated him hated him
hated them and this is all because he
was a freak it was outside of the norm
outside of the uh coloring lines a
little bit um he you know obviously you
got held back a little bit in the
beginning at that like monologue where
he's like oh i've been in high school
for this many years i don't you know he
was kind of ambiguous about it and uh
but he said this is finally going to be
his year um and we
we see we see him have that full hero
arc from beginning to end uh in the
beginning he doesn't have
any that many friends like he has the
hellfire club but they're you know
they're kind of like outskirts or
whatever
even as the storyline continues going on
they kind of end up fading away and we
end up getting him having just the most
honest true camaraderie with dustin um
which is you know one of another beloved
character in the series so so ultimately
when eddie ends up dying at the end it's
just one of the most heart-wrenching
moments especially for somebody like
from dustin's point of view because that
was really a role model he could look up
to him eddie's not the most ideal role
model but he is definitely a good person
because when when christy came to him to
ask him to buy drugs he actually gave
christy good advice um he genuinely
cared for the rest of the people and he
was a legit metal rock and roller like
when they had that moment when they were
playing the the the guitar on top of the
on top of the trailer to attract the
bats that was amazing so eddie's my
favorite character this season yeah that
was that was a contender for me for best
season four moments right there uh two
sort of outcasts that that met their
fate in the show so you are getting our
listeners and our viewers emotional here
back to you andres for your rebuttal
stumping for max yeah i i like that we
chose the two characters that had the
exact same death moment
uh in the show but yeah i feel i love
eddie i think he definitely had plenty
to do this season when it comes to a new
character
but at the end of the day it is a new
character and it is limited episodes
that we got with fetty versus someone
like max who we've built up since season
two uh we we've known max for a while
now and and her having this arc where
she continues to grow and she continues
to be a beloved character to me was even
more effective and her having that
moment in episode four with running up
that hill and her having that moment in
episode four with confronting vecna
fighting vecna and listening to the
music to break free is a moment that we
really felt because we felt like we were
part of what max has already been
through and we know what she's been
through because we've seen it versus
eddie we kind of get hints as his
background we get we kind of get hints
as far as where he comes from but we
don't really know too too much we just
kind of see his actions and we
appreciate him but at the end of the day
we know max and we appreciate max much
more because we know exactly what she's
been through because we've seen it all
throughout the entire uh show of
stranger things since season two so i
feel like max has a little bit more meat
on the bone when it comes to a
character-wise and that's why her
moments in season four to me were far
more impactful a little more of a
groundwork laid there a foundation set
in previous seasons but but robert as
you mentioned eddie came in with a and
went out with a bang too so i'll give
you your rebuttal now good sir i can't
argue that max has been around longer
she's definitely a key character and she
had like you know like we both said she
had an amazing moment with the running
up the hill scene and just everything
she'd been through this season she she
had a lot of stuff going on with that
being said though with eddie he was
actively being hunted by the entire town
over a dnd right over dungeons and
dragons which you know sounds crazy now
but you know uh for a lot of for a lot
of people and a lot of households and a
lot of communities frankly fantasy you
know card games and stuff like that is
just outright criminalized he was
demonized just for being himself and
just for being who he was and i think to
me that's what makes makes me relate to
eddie a little bit more because i
personally you know i when i grew up i
didn't i wasn't allowed to watch like
harry potter or lord of the rings and
stuff like that because it you know seen
as like not like appropriate so i could
definitely see from the perspective of
he's somebody who's been running his
entire life he's been you know he's
running from
the guys who the basketball team people
who jason who were chasing them and
literally about to hunt him and trying
to kill him he's running from you know
vecna and all all these other things
he's running from his own past and
trauma so but at the end he finally
stops running and takes control of his
own life and has that heroic moment that
heroic ending moment whereas max max
when she goes out i felt like dang man
she went out off of something that was
you know like she she we knew how to
fight vector already and she fought back
already and she still couldn't defeat
you know it wasn't her fault but still
it's like we already had that face off
of vector and she loses the second time
it's like that's kind of a weak way to
take an amazing character out eddie had
an amazing intro and outro within this
season so that's why i'm giving him
that's why i'm giving him the season
four price so eddie maybe went out with
a bigger bang you would say than max but
it seems like both both characters have
won y'all's hearts and even though you
have to argue for one or the other it's
like no you're making some good points
here too i like what's happening right
now back to you andres for your final
statement and possibly the most
competitive round thus far when it comes
to max a lot of people kind of forget
where she's coming from where her
relationship with billy kind of looking
back in season two in season three her
speech talking about how she felt about
billy and her conflicted feelings to
vecna talking about how she wasn't sure
if he deserved to live was a very
compelling moment in a compelling speech
and and it shows you that her heart is
in a place where her broken home and her
trauma not just from uh her life but
from billy himself and seeing billy die
and seeing billy go out as a hero she
wasn't sure how to feel about it and i
feel like that's such a relatable moment
as well besides her broken home aspect
besides her class aspect besides
everything else she's been through i
feel like that's a huge factor as far as
who max is and then her looking towards
the future
and her trying to place her feet on the
ground and not just rely on her past
trauma and realize what's in front of
her with lucas and her relationship with
lucas to me is the best part of the
entire show it might might be the best
relationship in the entire show and it's
between two of the younger kids
maybe even more than mike and 11 who
people have kind of softened on or
soured on uh because i feel like when it
comes to max and lucas that relationship
really sold you on what is the potential
of what max can bring versus when it
comes to eddie i feel like his potential
was lived throughout those few episodes
where his arc was complete whereas max
her arc feel like it was just getting
started it was just cooking and you just
felt so connected to her that you just
want to see more of max as much as you
can because you want her to grow with
lucas as as long as she can live
versus eddie you kind of know and you
kind of expect exactly what the stranger
things writers are doing when they
introduce a character like him and you
kind of see his death coming versus max
you you just feel like you want to spend
more time with her and you want her to
have that long life with lucas so a
little more unprepared for max's faith
than we were eddie's robert butler iii
you have the final statement eddie would
have easily been in either in jail or
dead if it wasn't for something like the
hellfire club right if it wasn't for the
community that he built amongst the
people who he built it with and he was
even though he wasn't the most exuberant
leader in in the world and he didn't
have the most academic credentials he
was a leader amongst his people and he
was a role model to dustin seeing that
relationship that eddie and dustin had
built up throughout the season and
seeing that as you said undress that
complete arc that we saw from eddie to
me that's what makes him a more
fulfilling character to me because we
saw
somebody who had who had potential who
had hope for the first time in his life
actually has some potential going
forward and like a upstarting chance and
he ended up having that cut short but in
the most epic way possible ended up
going out and while protecting like i
said a town that was actively fighting
against him actively going against him
and even after his death there were
still they're still talking negatively
about him and you know even his uncle
had to come to the thing and was you
know didn't even have any details about
how he died so it's it's all traumatic
all around for for eddie it's traumatic
for max too but that's why i just
personally vibe with with eddie's uh
storyline in this season yeah
representing hawkins a lot better than
hawkins represented eddie and so when we
look at these two characters i don't
know what it is i i can't stand watching
teenagers kids at school get bullied on
on tv program it just it gets inside my
soul somehow i didn't like it with
eleven didn't like with that he didn't
don't like it with anyone but when we
look at these two characters i do think
that max had the the leg up going into
season four because we did have a
relationship already that we had built
up and so i think it really is neck and
neck as far as who had the more
interesting season who had the more
uphill literal and figurative battle to
fight here but when we talk about them
meeting their fate their demise it
happened to both eddie and max but i
side slightly more with andres where it
was just so unexpected with max and i
think that retroactively that made me
care more about that character and and
robert knows better than most how hard
it is for me to vote against a guitar
player named eddie but i am going to go
with max with andres and so andres gets
the point here in round number three and
it is two to one as we head into round
number four and that is simply going to
be titled what is the most shocking
moment and we're going to start back
with robert butler iii to me the most
shocking moment easily came in episode 4
at the briar's house when will jonathan
and mike are just all chilling um they
just order some pizza from their boy
argyle they think it's on the way and
the fbi agent opens the door they get a
knock opens the door boom gets capped
right there and i don't know where we
get the most massive amazingly beautiful
shot one take long take um shootout
sequence that happens right in the
middle of the episode and it's
mind-blowing like we see asian hanson
who out of nowhere like i didn't think
this this chubby you know par boiler can
do was going to have it in him but he
ends up just like slaying him like he he
just ends up like defending almost the
entire
takes out almost an entire unit of
military people um
by himself so i thought that was really
really dope it was it was just so
shocking because it literally came out
of nowhere like there was an emotional
scene with with the briars that were
that led up to that and then there were
emotional scenes like that were in the
middle of that episode that were leading
up to that too but there were there was
no indication that there was going to be
a shootout like this there was no
indication there'd be things and they
obviously hinted towards the conflict
between the military and the the
researchers and the science people who
are trying to help
11 and things of that nature and that's
a very classic sci-fi
concept and trope that you know could
date back all the way back to like the
1950s um but this was the way they like
blew it up literally um to like this
all-out shootout um was just amazing to
me i thought it was really really cool
and before and then when argyle actually
pulls up and then he sees and then they
have to like jump into his car and he's
like hey what's up guys why is there
somebody carrying a gun and they're like
drive like what's wrong with you so i
love i loved everything about that scene
yeah and they tricked us into that whole
sequence with what every kid loves the
most is pizza delivery every kid or me
last night andres cabrera over to you
for your most shocking moment in
stranger things
yeah i feel like my most shocking moment
comes in the finale
and that's when max gets crushed and she
gets killed by vecna and we see her
obviously
lose her life in front of lucas
i feel like that moment kind of shocked
everyone because we all expect someone
like an eddie someone like adjacent
someone would like a brenner to die
because we know those kind of characters
are kind of finding their way out of the
show but when it comes to someone like
max we've known her from season two so
seeing her
not just die but die in the one of the
most brutal ways we've ever seen in the
show to me was one of the most shocking
moments and it completely broke me uh
and i think it broke a lot of people
watching that scene because when we see
deaths in the past we've seen deaths
when it comes to characters that tend to
skew you a tiny bit older whether it
comes to sean aston's character uh
whether it comes to alexis character or
even eddie who's an older uh teenager
but when it comes to max someone who's
so young and who's whose face sadie
sings face
still looks so young compared to some of
the other kids who already look older
but sadie still looks like a little girl
seeing her die in that horrific manner
and lucas crying over her and us buying
into that relationship and buying into
that character so much especially after
season four and running up that hill and
her escaping from the upside down to me
was by far the most shocking moment i'll
pick two good ones again here back to
you robert butler iii for your rebuttal
i don't know if i would consider the
maxine the most shocking um because a
you know they set up the entire uh
finale for her to have that
confrontation with beckman so we knew
she was going to have that con
confrontation with vecna either way it's
going to go one or two ways she don't
live or she's gonna die right um so like
you know it's like it it's it's gonna be
it's shocking how i guess it might have
happened but that's also the thing too i
don't know if she actually dies or not i
mean she clearly goes blind she clearly
like loses a bunch of limbs and she
clearly like goes into a coma and they
say she dies for like a minute but there
is no reason why they would like keep
her body in the hospital and keep her
like living for that long if they
weren't planning on bringing her back
next season so like
all that being said it kind of like to
me undercuts that moment a little bit um
and it just doesn't like resonate as
much for me but i will not there's no
exaggerating when i tell you i was
laughing so hard when that shootout
scene started because i was just on my i
was just literally like playing like a
like a water game like a phone game on
my phone or something like that and i
don't know where you just hear like
ar-15s going no out of nowhere and
you're like yo what's what is this like
how did this happen like you just think
there's mad kids talking so it was
shocking in the sense of it literally
came out of nowhere it literally like
woke you up shocked you and is and um in
the context you know it's one of those
beautiful like tarantino scenes right
where something big happens and they
explain it to you like after they
explain everything that happens like
afterwards so when we get the
explanation from adrian hansen like yo
these are the people who are looking for
11 they're coming after you and ends up
dying and giving that phone number to
them and ends up setting them on a whole
different path for a new adventure those
new characters i thought it was i
thought it was really good and i thought
that was in the season where mike will
and jonathan were sidelined that was
definitely definitely a highlight moment
for those three new kids in your phones
put the phone away when you're watching
stranger things robert let's go back to
andres cabrera for your rebuttal yeah i
i almost feel like you undercut your
argument by telling by telling us you
were on your phone uh but at the same
time i just feel like when it comes to
measuring a season or when it comes to
measuring his show
and you say to yourself okay
what moment just really kind of shocked
me broke me moved me just completely
took me out of my entire comfort zone
and just pulled me out and i feel like
when it comes to a shootout yeah it's a
cool moment it's a cool kind of like
whoa this is crazy but it lasts like
three four minutes versus a moment with
max with her dying and you're you don't
even know her fate until the very end of
that action scene when they're trying to
kill vecna uh when hopper's trying to
kill the demogorgon when 11 is fighting
vecna at the same time like there's four
different fights going on at the same
time while max is being killed and i
feel like that even adds stakes to it
because you're so concerned about max so
seeing her finally meet her fate at the
very end of all that kind of breaks
everything down it kind of takes you out
of your comfort zone takes you out of
your moment
and kind of shocks you to the core and
makes you realize like oh damn we were
just having this heroic moment where
nancy wheeler was just like wielding a
shotgun and shooting vector in the face
and now we're we're crying our eyes out
because we lost one of the greatest
characters we've ever had in the show
and i agree that maybe she's not
necessarily gone but in that moment
we sure thought she was gone and lucas
made us believe she was gone because he
was crying like crazy and giving us the
performance of his life so i feel like
that moment itself just carried
everything in the entire season finale
when it comes to the heart of the show
when it comes to the action when it
comes to like oh cool gunfight like we
can see that in other shows but when it
comes to stranger things you want to see
heart and i think heart came from max
more than any other character and her
being crushed in that moment just
crushed our hearts more than any other
moment inside stranger things it was it
was certainly and i i don't mean a pun
intended it was certainly a breaking
point it was very very tough to watch
and so as far as the just the visceral
shocking moments we now are at the final
statement stage to you first mr butler
well i'm just going just going off of
what you were saying on dressless when
when that and then
like when when max was getting killed
there was a lot going on there was demi
goran's being fought in russia there
were you know uh
mad other conflicts going on at the same
time and that's to me is what really
undercut the the shockingness of it it
felt like just one part of a bigger
action scene one part of a bigger finale
which was already part of a plan you
know it was already part of the plan
that she was gonna have to go through
that process um
now what wasn't part of the plan was her
getting either dead or crippled or
whatever but um again like if if they're
gonna bring her back that undercuts
caleb's amazing caleb who plays lucas
amazing performance um when we think
she's dead so it's like you know what
was the point of that anyway and to me
that's why i chose the the shootout
scene because it feels so much more
isolated it's not part of like a bigger
action scene it's not part of like a
finale it literally just happened in the
middle of an episode randomly shockingly
um and then it it it goes in it goes out
and we still see the ramifications of it
for those three characters throughout
the rest of the season so um that to me
is why i'm probably i probably will say
when it comes to the most shocking
moment i would say
i'll say that when it comes to like the
most you know heartbreaking
you know deaf or most heartbreaking
moment i'll definitely go with max but
when it comes to shocking there's
nothing more shocking than the shootout
especially at my at the the briar's
house and it's a good point because that
shootout wasn't just an isolated thing
it did have legs that stretched well
into future episodes so uh andres
cabrera you have the final statement
here in round number four
yeah i almost feel like
measuring that moment when it comes to
the weight on the characters
is kind of interesting right because we
we meet that agent guy
and then we get that shootout and then
he dies but i don't know if there's that
many
ripple waves when it comes to the
characters because obviously they bury
him they kind of do this kind of goofy
scene with argyle writing minister agent
on his grave and then finding the pen
and all that but i don't feel like
there's actually any stakes that came
from that or any emotional stakes that
came from that i feel like when it comes
to shocking moments you have to have
some sort of emotional stakes and what's
more of an emotional stakes than lucas
losing his mind over max being
potentially dead whether she's
eventually dead or not is another
question but in that moment we realized
that she is dead and i feel like luke is
realizing that and us as an audience
seeing lucas's heartbreak was more
heartbreaking than any moment we've seen
shown was more shocking at any moment
because we don't expect someone like max
to die in that manner versus seeing an
agent get shot in a show you know that's
just par for the course when it comes to
stranger things but seeing max get
crushed by an evil dark demon wizard
lab rat experiment
you know brother of 11
kind of character like avecna is
that's something we don't expect because
we've seen her escape from the upside
down so we don't expect her to once
again go back in the upside down and die
in the same manner that we didn't want
her to die all the way back in season
four so seeing that as an audience we
were just like no no no because
that's exactly what we're trying to
avoid back in episode four so seeing it
eventually happen in the finale
to me that's the most shocking in all of
stranger things both of these moments
they all were talking about were at
least surprising i think to everyone
watching stranger things and you know
max is just one of those characters that
you just intrinsically care about and so
that's going to up the shock value but
but it's not just a shock it's also just
a hard thing to watch it's a hard thing
to process but i'm going to bring up my
favorite and possibly the greatest star
wars movie of all time return of the
jedi there's a scene towards the end and
ewok gets capped and oh my god is it
heartbreaking but the thing that saves
it is that immediately we cut back to a
space battle because as robert pointed
out there's a bunch of other stuff going
on during the point when max is getting
crushed whereas with just for a pure
visceral shock moments i do feel like
robert's had a little more just oh my
god i can't believe that happened in the
moment and so i might be a little more
emotional a lot more emotional towards
max but as far as just the pure shock
value i think it's the moment that made
rb3 laugh the hardest and if you've ever
heard that laugh at a comedy club it can
power an entire town so i'm going to
give the point to robert here and that
means that we are tied we are also
running short on time so we're going to
go to a sudden death round but it's
going to be lightning quick here's what
i need from each of my competitors you
get no more than 30 seconds here and the
the round is going to be decided by the
question that is what is the best season
of stranger things so you can pick any
season you want that's already aired
we're going to start with andres again
30 seconds at most on the clock because
we got to go quick what's the best
season
best season is season two it's when the
characters came into their own it's when
steve harrington became the hero that we
all knew he could be he became the most
charming character in the show eleven
came into her own she realized who she
was dustin came into his own he got his
own confidence back we introduced the
character of max in the show who's
become one of the most favorite
characters of the entire show season two
had the most complete arc of any season
of syringe things
you just nailed that presentation i
think that was exactly 30 seconds too
well done sir you came prepared robert
butler it's it's now sort of like a hill
that you have to climb for your i guess
rebuttal but this is going to be also
your final statement what is the best
season in your opinion of stranger
things
well i think our the best season is
honestly season four the season we just
watched um i loved how it took uh kids
most emotionally serious
confronting themes of bullying mental
health grief trauma you know these are
all things that a lot of kids actually
deal with in the mental health field so
it was very empowering that they
talked about those subjects also david
david harbor had a way more creative and
suspenseful russian prison escape scene
here than he had in black widow just
saying um also um another amazing moment
robin taking the stance to the dean's
office taking a stand you know like
speaking on gender equality and higher
education and of course liz undress said
everything with max in the season was
amazing including the usage of the k
bush iconic song how much clearance they
had to get for that um in order to use
that apparently they have to like super
convince her um and the budget was like
super dope too it was like the biggest
spectacle tv i've ever seen so
wow all right so we got to compile all
of that into one decision rendered by me
i love the point that david harbor
suddenly really good at escaping russian
prisons so uh congrats to you hopper as
for your character and black widow as
well oh man this is tough because season
two i feel like season two was had such
a challenge in front of it because it
had to follow this
incredible surprise hit that we all
loved from season one and then season
two some fans might have thought it was
a little bit of a letdown or the story
got a little wonky but andres makes a
lot of great points as far as the
characters themselves coming into their
own but then you see season four and you
see all of the the toys that they had to
play with you mentioned the budgetary
concerns the sandbox gets a little
bigger we have more characters to sort
of pull from and to tug on our
heartstrings with including max
including an eddie and so i
in the sudden death round i do have to
side slightly personal preference aside
i gotta go with robert butler iii here
with season four it may be recency bias
for both of us robert and you know that
as well as i do but as of right now i
got i'll go back and watch season two
for you andres i'm gonna go back and
watch season two so i i reserve the
right to change my mind well after this
episode has aired and maybe when we get
episode or season five it's gonna blow
everything else out of the water that's
certainly a hope for a lot of stranger
things fans well robert butler is your
champion here today but this might be
the best played match i've ever seen
here on binge battle and you could not
ask for two better competitors for two
better people to be arguing pros and
cons of stranger things then starting
with our winner robert butler iii where
can all the kids out there find you is
there a chance that we get to see your
hit movie the short film time stamp out
there sooner rather than later
yeah there it will be out there very
soon on amazon prime video so make sure
you i'll if you make sure you follow me
on twitter and instagram director rb3
for all the details
alrighty and andres cabrera you didn't
even come up short today we just
basically ran out of time we could have
done this for 10 more rounds i feel like
um where can everybody check you out and
i also want to give a shout out to the
first cut y'all's channel because i in
prep for this did watch y'all stranger
things for take and and it really was
enlightening i if you're a stranger
things fan out there you've got to go
subscribe to uh to the first cut right
now and check out that review it was
really really well done where can
everybody else find all the good stuff
you're working on
yeah obviously as you mentioned before
first co we have our stranger things
spoiler review uh four season four part
one and two up right now we also have
our thor love and thunder with rb3 and
sabrina up as well review there we're
going to be dropping more reviews there
as well you can find me at squad leader
ace on twitter and instagram so yeah
check that out all right a lot of good
streaming shows you all cover obviously
a lot of big time and some movies that
are off the beaten path so keep up the
great work on the first cut subscribe
there on youtube as for us here at
rotten tomatoes just go to
rottentomatoes.com for all the latest in
the world of movies television and
everything in between including possibly
updates as to when we can expect a new
stranger things season to drop as for us
here for our steamed engineer christian
rubel cabba for molly the wonder dog who
is storing so loud i can't believe it
again picked up in this ear mic i am
merely mark ellis you can find me at
mark ellis live upcoming comedy tour
dates mark ellis dot live thanks for
tuning in to binge battle and we'll see
y'all next time right here at rotten
tomatoes
you